welcome to the were soul food podcast
we're back around and I'm always back
I'm going to where I'm over here man
they got me here enough on a lifetime
contract one song fool she goes back
from Mexico yeah men with cracking dog
was so broke people tell you're not
going to come back who did he talk about
he's gone for a week but the only thing
was from Wednesday to Wednesday and my
fights were in the day so let's do for a
wedding right
no my cousin graduated it on the
Saturday so we went for that but one who
spent three days beforehand three days
after you took your lady with you yeah
man good invited her she invited herself
well I invited her for only be if you
got a lady what are you gonna go to
places by yourself dog it I mean okay I
love you will do that wrong you can't
believe that role then somebody is the
best restaurant dogs are myself and
somebody's gonna also get a tuck in your
lady dog
what so fool judges anything good over
there to the bomb is whatever what you
have this is everything done Wow
but I didn't want to know what
everything is everything is rockin
tamales Mexican tamales Y got some olive
oil made out of well they wrap them in a
in a the downloader not under the same
but they're different they're like
square opposed to being like oval also
had some bomb-ass stuff that I had last
time was of the model or square like
victory banana leaf or a banana leaf
because it stuck down in the south south
but one of the Bombers things that I had
last time it's a bomb I don't know if
you ever had it was a chicharrón is a
football which is a fried octopus
though which was bomb as hell dude and I
blow in such that our octopus tastes
like hard it's rubbery it not it was a
nice and soft but they do it enough to
um so uh alright I'll keep on going cuz
there are about twelve things though
that I have the Obamas book I waiting
for more with octopus the octopus bomb
is hell on the it's the arm not the tip
tips but from like we're the the handle
sort of wave the suction port all that
part and part ride with flour or not
enough what I don't know what I think
it's just lightly fried
but they come out crisp dude on the
outside and you cut it it's nice and
soft in the middle dude it was bombed I
had it last time at this place called
the sonora grill this time it was in
poor video right there in Polanco in
Mexico City what it is over with they
serve it with welcome on any server with
salsas they celebrate with the lime in
tortillas so you can make tacos and a
side of Reef lies refried black beans do
and a little bit of dry cheese on the
top not so much good so fresco but I
think it's like dried Piniella not your
first time having that second time
well yeah but your lady like that yeah
she's dead people yeah I don't no matter
what I should have said tamales the last
super mixta not oh yeah man and they had
peace ever have pieces of bomb after put
it was always hard
it was always hard like that robbery you
know and one thing though I think it was
used to be hard because I sure wasn't
fresh stuff no yeah that's another
reason that's what I believe cuz I've
ate at the same spot before yeah yeah
and then you know la ku tambien cuz that
stuff right there is you know they do it
with lime right and if they don't leave
it long enough it's not gonna soften up
as much do you get home good tacos the
do the bomb is tacos ever dog they don't
get better than I let all of people self
tremendous it will be over there really
good food it is [ __ ] suck apparel to
let as good as what which was in la
jeunesse Playa I don't want to be a dick
or nothing but you can like you know
that thing is all different are
incomparable is code but the TaylorMade
their to their tortillas are made there
and the thing is with the tortillas in
Mexico fool and not all of them now
because now a lot of stuffs getting
important to the ranches the tortillas
are made they're fresh and they don't
have any preservatives because those are
the tortillas that after they become
worn they harden up yeah so there's that
much better the case different I
remember the tortillas man yeah yeah
well Lisa makes our flour tortillas
they're soft
once we eat up but once you put them in
that bag maybe they're super hard yeah
dude I mean you can revive them and
bring them back to life on the command
but when they come out freshly that's
the best way to have them do and I'm if
I saw totally do that if you want them
to a one goes to a WTO to go they would
just cook them a little bit minute you
just finish warm open your house
I do and well that is mondo mondo the
tortilla King man 8:30 I got a bottle
that hit their friend Genesis we talk
about buttery I didn't do it I didn't
really follow my road I don't think it's
much dude I think it says nothing that I
can recall you know when you get toward
tortillas they don't want serve you
butter with it dude I mean not like here
but you have any in there like watch and
they Li hua those any no no no none of
that stuff that always tears up shakes
when he's at home go back one thing that
I had that I didn't have last time was I
had cochinita pibil which was bomb at
three spots but I had about what is that
cochinita pibil is uh is for from the
Yucatan area of Mexico when you got on
Peninsula but it's a pork but it's
marinating like a reddish chili and it's
just everything to put together and they
mix it all up and it's nice and soft
that place over there off the hill hers
has it but it's not as good as that
thing no way it's dried Oh eternal more
that place uh that little taco stand
next yeah um you've got that you can
take oh yeah yeah that plays a barbarian
food yeah that's good but it just isn't
as good as that place - oh no I know it
going there now in his [ __ ] bomb
but what I didn't have last time is like
Cuyler this every other right yeah it's
almost full English yes yes and it's a
series of that [ __ ] and it's not the
whole the pork when it's old I think
it's like a young little pig dude so
that's much more softer and yeah man I
think Lisa has perfected that red sock
when she made her tamales but she makes
more litt know what she meant when she
forcefully yeah because that's what me
yes male s it has a leaf I like a leaf
they's alleles are there when they pack
it in there they put that in there but
um but what I didn't have last time was
Amanita a particle which is the help aw
yeah the hand right there from the the
wrist to the roll and what they do it
they bake it in that stuff and it comes
out super soft dude the tendons in there
I get a big debate La Moneda the front
the hand of the pig right yeah yeah not
that not the hind ones and it's a super
bomb and I've had them before the fryer
with water but no they they bake it now
with butter just put that stuff that
they're doing
same thing Juanita paviva got the nails
off another now not therefore
everything's there you suck all that
[ __ ] off you slice it off yeah you put
it in your mouth about rubbery it's the
tendons and we'll meet the little
ratchet or oh yeah yeah but it's not
chitchat Ron dude that's the thing
because I've had it with Cheech I've run
this before in carnitas where they put
those in there because everything gets
used even the [ __ ] tail and um it's
really good but I think this is even
better but that was balm that I had well
they're like stuff delicious food and
I'm in a Mexico City that it's hard to
copy that you don't see an Electra much
because it's illegal or just the time it
takes to prepare there just wouldn't be
enough time to me to make money on that
time um I think a lot of stuff that's
all hip stirred up and like you know
there was a popular here any like that
one where the pork had beat up
yeah that because it's hard to make it
because they make it in a different I
think deep they put in like a deep thing
so we get out here no mortar or that
matter said that I was of course one
technique remember I want to go eat that
um barbacoa they can't do it they're
just because Texas help law forbid them
to put stuff under the dirt well people
get away with it huh
yeah but I'm sure you can't go
advertising that [ __ ] maybe how she can
do it but um that was bomb as hell dude
I'm the tackles that are made out of the
tortillas were made out of no pun or
Miller green green so see ya there and
um and that was poppin I was I was good
Lisa yeah and those were cultural tier
middle of a cactus and they were green
and those were I guess from the Oaxaca
area but that was at that particular
restaurant porphyrios enough Polanco
which we talked about three or four
different regions of feud but um that
was bomb as hell too what kind of stuff
Mexican food that considered Mexican
food it down over here it doesn't even
exist over there Mexico burritos no
bridges there's no burritos there's just
talk also stink huh no there's the
burritos permit North America well even
though Mexico North America black show
some nachos or American dude
exactly yeah that's my Mexican food yeah
started enough supposedly for the border
right there cuts by a watt is and all
that nineteen everyone watched it was a
chip with a cheesy jalapeno
I suppose it was like I think we read it
up one day every chips and two beers
he's on her quesadilla Jade I was asked
to go there but therefore tostada ha
yeah they cook them a little bit more
where the cheeses like falling out yeah
now they have one that's called a
quesadilla gringa I saw in someone's
page that I did what I got to eat they
get a leg for stood you up in a cage oh
yeah I had a video soil yeah yeah laughs
he had a pool he went to a play with
they're making quesadillas put the
quesadilla was not like ours it was like
it was like it was there barbecuing so
they put a flat corn tortilla with up
with mine I got a Monterey Jack and they
just did just let that [ __ ] bake
and they put meat on top yeah hell yeah
Jesus Island like I don't know if that's
called Amelita but they have a lot of
those mojitos or corn tortillas they
also had a lot of gorditas like that
opposed to the ones in Mexico - yeah
dude Bob there is in South been granted
to market - it's like they're good
they're a grand total market they're
really tasty they're really delicious
but this is just the next level for you
can't compare it it's a stock with a
soft and crunch at the same time that
time - but the lady is making the water
heaters has been making it and she's
been 30 years old and she's $70 right
there how I really made her beauty -
dude no prepping Cheniere huh no
prepping it's all it's all like second
nature dome like for instance he's uh um
the last day I was there we had um the
first time we had a show huh -
definitely a show it's art dude if we
had a taco episode which we didn't
really have because we know we're
running around doing a bunch of other
[ __ ] so the dude has a pineapple on top
the onion on the bottom the meat in the
middle he's got that yeah but he's
waiting for everything to get crispy
then he's doing a cut and get you a taco
after he does that he's with a sword I
posted a little video on snapchat
he snatches a piece of [ __ ] us I
looked at my chat they snatch is a piece
of pineapple a slice puts it on that
taco dude
whether you want to for under Odin is
usually five whichever I really let our
type of our past or and vegan and
chicken vegan then I'm vegan and I seen
a plant up on top a teeny only on top
but Aikido has never cut a piece of
onion and a piece of pineapple put in my
taco and I'm thinking why I always
thought that that was just for looks but
he's never hooked me up like that so I
gotta ask over here in America you have
to ask for before that sounds good like
a wise like a little bit of me earlier
like I remember eating them I think with
Lisa we're eating a pineapple pizza and
I will opportunity I would like to
to post or the pineapple way the opening
- I wouldn't use to that you know just
doing a pineapple wait you wanna I don't
want order two pizzas whatever but man
that sounds good I like pineapple pizza
when the she gets a little bit burnt all
right now I wanna know I mean what's the
problem people have enough cuz I've seen
a lot of means that people are anti
pineapple pizza dawg
I think it's delicious I feel you guys
like piece of ham forget about it oh
yeah but um about dr. de jamon you know
we seen him but we didn't have a top of
the jamon we had tortoises chorizo from
um
Toluca which is the chorizo shred like
you know normally he could read but this
one's red red like almost crayon red
it's been a pork or beef pork and that's
a different type of chorizo from that
part of Mexico this is right next it's
but maybe I throw there has I seen it
they were all they hung it up rolled it
up and then you they slice it and they
cut it up when you had it taste when
they uh when you hate it you either like
chorizo style or like ground beefy or
lowball no they had it in a bhalil they
cut the whole deal they put a little bit
of mayonnaise they [ __ ] put it down
on the grill cook that up
they put slices of avocado slices of
tomato slices of onion lettuce and then
the chorizo in there with a layer of
batter room no I did come fatter for
I've been decompressing the last week I
was enormous well you ain't no bread in
love and oh god it was just too much we
have so much cheese for how much she
didn't really know much meat knife
Oliver machaca
a nun I don't know much over there I
just do that I didn't try any I am oh
you know what I did I had my Chuck on my
eggs but the French my choco best not
the shredded dry one like so notice ah
how about uh how about it's a little
mixture of nationality now so they like
though they mix it like Thai food with
fat Mexican style one thing fusing I
don't really know too much about that
what I did see there's a lot of Chinese
restaurants and more Thai but supposedly
the Chinese food in Mexico's off the
hook but we just didn't have enough time
to try it'sa pizzas everywhere dude but
it's all I dude it's a 24-hour city dude
everything Thai food Chinese food Indian
food Russian food all types of [ __ ] dude
straight a hotel no I my cousin's pad
right there
yeah though do but the food is dude it's
just different dude I mean I don't know
the last time you went to Mexico or
whatever but it'd be if you remember
beat the
smells are different it just smells
better dog he just sits there fool um I
remember there was a good president
nothing just over at a at a farmers
market him and I'm p1 of Mexico and
we're buying like a lot of stuff man
we're buying a lot of stuff what I
cheese a lot of stuff stocking up and
then we went to the play with all candy
man nothing but bees all over the place
yeah something like and then I'm and
then a bundle said that guy opened up
the coke the he took the blanket the
sheet of the bundle sent to show us
[ __ ] bees came out of nowhere bro
attacked it for some good at Babu's war
broke without a blanket we did try some
over there didn't it just dude like here
after a while dude wherever you get it
it gets a little hard it's good
whatever over there do you bite into it
it's [ __ ] soft melts in your mouth
dude over here still here when your
backbone shot is a cold shot brush
before he can hit somebody with it and
once I hit those do we have some gansito
to we brought some bad though there's no
more dog you freeze them huh
we didn't freeze them here we just
brought them all just like style in
packs of three because that way they
don't get smashed but um yeah man
my mom is [ __ ] man before we get to our
shoutouts man Yemen we were at the Tempe
improv last week it was hilarious
sold-out shows crystalline order here
bro
well I'm a different team member a
little way bro
I'm like a kid again when you lost Chris
Brown I lost like a body bro yeah he
looks so skinny I'm tiny bro he just
happened to be here huh growl I haven't
been this happy in like six months bro
yeah but you should happen in that big
dilemma look at this little Broglie well
I love the Disneyland to Fresno bro all
right man good to have you here Chris
was wrong fool oh man
we had [ __ ] we had um much a drizzle
and Tempe and therefore was I'm doing
that a bit or the taping of um to start
the behind the scenes and taking photos
you know something man you I don't have
time to do all that time and you gotta
get somebody to put a video up let
everybody know what's going on you know
we're happy we're living life to the
fullest having a good time numb
start [ __ ] so what's awful so
the [ __ ] Saturday night man I don't
know what's going on everybody say their
goodbyes I meet much original morning
this was talking about he made a cougar
coming about he's she's 50 years old
twice his age so what happened was you
turn up here I've never heard a
different door of it I took first of all
he shared a room with Rodrigo
so I heard I eat he told me that he took
her to the room and Regina was sleeping
and then I saw somebody else in here and
as soon as she said it instead of
someone else in here so he started a
party hotdog I did I don't know right
I knew honey was going on because the
thing is like I can get woken up right
away with any little creak a light a
little mouse walks on the door I want to
exterminate it right
Robert Robert stop binky so this will
comes in all right cool it's cool if you
want to get laid or whatever but doesn't
this lady have a houseful well she's a
native dude a tepee or something in the
hallway whatever it's cool dogs were the
vision yeah tonight she's 50 bro I know
dude she should only have inheritance
money dog what's going on here
Christy perhaps to hit a breaking
bachelors that's what I'm saying dude
did you know parks where we're over
that's what I'm saying dude go take her
underneath the gazebo through the car
yeah that's what she have a car either
you're the one or what what's your buddy
listed in a green room that's what I'm
saying dude [ __ ] there's a lockout man
you know what I would say for now we hit
an hour to bring someone in the green la
la did right even backstage
yeah dude helped imagine a restroom it's
gonna be romantic wait what - like
candles yeah otherwise she's smelling
farts in her feet so anyways I knew
somebody would come in but I'm not
hating you know what whatever do your
business dude Una's go to sleep but I
can't sleep so as soon as she opened up
oh no she saw what happened what brush
heel toe your set bro oh this says
really young man he [ __ ] give me a
fort no you laid out so I was covered up
though but as soon as she came in she
wash her hands I heard little speaks and
stuff whatever so I was and I sleep I
sleep dude I sleep only in my underwear
my tighty whities so I just took the
covers off yeah like [ __ ] be
masculine
super my dad bro with no mask when I'm
higher dog he gets hot and it's 65
degrees can I keep the van AC on kick in
you intervene over the hundred outside
brought all my room never got higher
role in 72 was brutal dog I saw what hit
him a window is hard oh my god he put
the couch up and blocked that [ __ ]
sunray so she walks in the door
she washes her hand and I see her like I
could feel somebody I can feel the
energy of another body and he's just no
bro and I feel that little fools acting
different - he's like trying to be quiet
turns on the light sick [ __ ] use
the light from your cell phone be slick
dog so I take the [ __ ] I just take
the covers off I point my ass there
because I had all that gas from Mexico
City left dog because I was eating all
these [ __ ] fruits of vegetables
trying to [ __ ] flush it all out I
[ __ ] point my ass in the air dog so
you like [ __ ] hit the wall then
ricochet off the other wall and then hit
her in the face book you know I'm saying
I'm like a sniper bro then they can
shoot sparks out that room yeah you know
now dog Odie Georgia and brown I'm gonna
tell you Silent Bob this is how you
gonna gas the [ __ ] and I'm saying we
sleep like doctors we can't sleep like
that one there's women in the room
especially old [ __ ] ladies what is
this [ __ ] grandma in his mama to say
dime cop Champa so fool so as soon as
she [ __ ] speaks cool
I [ __ ] [ __ ] like bucket adjusted my
butthole fool like dude it was like I
was adjusting my foods like smoking weed
from Mexico dog and you [ __ ] puppet
all the seeds in the joint pool it was
like I even describe someone's mom
it was ferocious bro boo and then I'm
sure the [ __ ] smell with all the [ __ ]
I mean there's an old test in my stomach
issue state oh do this little
[ __ ] but brother Jews a fool
that weighs 90 pounds take on brand new
shoes and it smells like a [ __ ]
dumpster full sigh damn dude what's
going on with the youth of today
[ __ ] you well I say to a playboy [ __ ] it
to a skateboarder to iOS MP let's say
you the [ __ ] $30 mouthful so anyways
some issues are and there was a pause
for in the conversation right
like a pause like I don't know whether
to throw up or run out of the door so
for that was just round one dog for I
buckle down for some [ __ ] pulp or
[ __ ] carnitas or chicharrones - - mmm
so I gas them like Auschwitz boom no
survivors dude
hell yeah oh my god so that's what
happened for this you okay I'll see you
later bye so her he walked out and you
can tell him he's in the hallway like
doesn't know what to do that's how can
we go to her house she there 40 miles
away don't you a dog that's what I'm
saying what the [ __ ] there are so many
places to have stags around the building
bro I don't get it take a little orange
the swimming pool bro right nobody's
there
[ __ ] no and my whole thing is like dude
if I'm sharing a room with somebody dude
I mean you know if you bring somebody in
the room to have sex and it's not your
house
you know if was gonna be peeking you
know gonna be I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't care
rubber her feet but just pop in the tub
in your ass but uh yeah come on now you
gonna yeah I mean a chips I'm gonna want
that unless she's a freak you know he
catch bears - bro he Chester Street he
totally had a room oh yeah dude you
can't even what - crystal his condo
yeah he's aa brightest in a liberal bro
you told him the morning proud and I
would have Sutra with you bro you can do
whatever you want bro you got tough
times with old ladies bro I was out late
fall bro oh yeah how can only be 15
being prepared for I know first of all
if you're 50 I'm not even gonna talk to
you 50 we want a hug where you teach me
the ABCs are you gonna teach me the time
table square root of 40 cents who would
have put in a bed sing lullabies bug was
so cool let's talk about the weather but
it was a hundred and seven oh my god
Sunday was hot hot it was hot we didn't
do nothing but stay in a hotel we went
to the model bit came past what to the
Arizona Mills Mall man that [ __ ]
was sweaty it was even war everybody was
sucking the cold
rather there was our hottest bodies dude
who's like a hundred and seven outside
and there was like a rock a lot a lot of
people at the mall pack and it was it
was moist in there it was humid for
human man yeah with the Arizona Mills ma
ya did ya was cool though [ __ ] got a
little bit of gear right cover some
pants on Perry Alice were so full shout
outs upcoming shows over may 25th
through the 28th I'll be at the Irvine
improv that's today today Friday
Saturday Sunday okay check this out
Friday second show is sold out alright
tonight tonight's show is sold out okay
to national and sold out Saturday
showing sold out there's still some
tickets there for Sunday but hurry up we
added a second show on Sunday at 9:30 so
all these shows are sold out at the
Irvine improv so I would say mas see
that next time June 1st to the 4th
Arlington Texas at the Arlington improv
plenty of tickets available next week
we're coming
see you there boo July 1st to Sun
Arizona at the Ewa amphitheater with
Paul Rodriguez already we'll be doing
comedy before the concert with teairra
Marlowe and war in July I am also coming
to Corpus Christi Texas Tampa Florida
and Des Moines Iowa Des Moines Iowa
tell everybody check out Philippa
WorldCom's last tour for other show
dates and the rest of the year ok we
have a special special shout out from a
veteran a guy who served time in the
military and he wrote is a nice tweet
check this out we're gonna read it
shoutout to @x
Oh Matteo on Twitter X on my tail follow
him tell them thank you for providing
and protecting us from terrorism all
over the world at X Oh M a TT
a TT e o tell em thanks
once tofu hey I'm behind hey I'm blind
and I just out the military after 10
years military intelligence unit I'm
Mexican but I look white I'm a me khlo I
just want to say thank you and Rodrigo
you guys helped me when I got in my
accident I just put your podcast on and
just head and I just put your podcast on
and just had been blind for three months
I want to say thank you you helped me
and entertain me throughout my whole
problem all my family is gang related
Lord Daniels
used to be now now that was so cool
now they got out but chillin with you
guys I felt like I was at a pajama party
just talking [ __ ] about life it's cool
man I'm starting a podcast with a guy
who delivered my weed he's from Salvador
he worked the door at Cobbs were gonna
sign a peace treaty man wouldn't that be
cool and violence I lost all my friends
in Salinas due to prison or death I'm
trying to find new friends now I just
want to say I live your carbs in San
Francisco if you ever need a place to
chill in San Francisco you got one Orion
fool take you very very much at my ex or
my bellboy
hell yeah intelligent abroad he got
blind in the military looking forward to
it though and now have full of care now
so I'm sort of podcast room that's
what's up man I'm talking a bit I see us
at okay podcast don't be one I'll be a
good neighbor I see us a lot a podcast
every year everyone who review to the
life tools chancla Van Damme in the high
E sub Franklin was have a son Caleb and
damn IE commutes from in deal to victor
real five days a week and say the
podcast keeps him from crashing like
John Jones on a crack bender damn he
owes 62
oh man before we even move on man check
this out I am movie man
right right I'll lay I'm out of Glendale
I'm going back to the LA County not to
turtle let me put my help over here okay
so and you guys know man Ross you go
waist waist thirty eight thirty eight
thirty to thirty eight thirty thirty
eight thirty home and I wear waist 42:30
sometimes I'm on to a time but lately I
also have pads that are forty thirty and
I have a lot of shirts that are
extra-large that could have a long torso
man I got you say I'm on tour so you
know it's first up like what am i well
like I like like I can't reach the gas
pedal and my [ __ ] head hits the top
of the car I'm shorter legs and I do a
tour so it's done man I'm on tour so
grab like a full nelson
thank you put your like I can help you
carry the couch but I gotta be in the
bottom of the stairs I can't be on top
she put up a picture that little dog
food I wasn't ever walking around some
guy goes by a bro you got some nice
leather pants brother boots anyway so
like I can't and funny I was in a car
and I couldn't reach it was outside a
Moodle seat forward and I couldn't
anymore and he goes that's it you know
you don't feel tight climb all being
right that's a cab with the cab they go
you don't feel like stop now mm oh right
look at my legs bro I can't even reach
the bit of front of the car your friend
could reach the back right off doctor
like if I had kids in the backseat like
a poker more bro my natural done anyway
so enough of a torso a bunny no hot so
the point is man we're moving out and
I'm going to invite anybody that wants
to come down to our own house and we're
gonna have a fat man yourself
yeah man fat man yard sale plus some
furniture for sale I let emerge a lot of
old merged with on sound or more a lot
of old CDs a lot of your large console
TV shows right I got a lot of stuff I
gotta get rid of
and it is so soft no no DEFCON close
that but yeah others to shirts right um
vintage well Jillian stuff by the way
back is a neat guy man like it'll heal
like all my shirt bro they've been
masturbated on and we watched I
guarantee you that's not a tie-dye shirt
bro anyway so it on is Johnny yeah you
know what I was drawn where those shirts
so we're already oh sure around point
and um we're gonna be selling a lot of
fat man stuff like I'm 38 and up yeah a
lot of my tennis shoes will be out there
man I might be selling my coat from the
first special oh [ __ ] a lot of stuff
will be there for sale we ever guest
here man his [ __ ] khaki might be for
sale like chance get him a romper oh I
know where's vessel yes we're gonna have
a big yard sale man in a couple of weeks
on letter a lot of the were so full
podcast post Adobe or sell to other
disco but WR fail I love my CD geo CD
negativo you're sure to be on sale yeah
but most of my teacher will be like $2
are you giving out an address for this
not yet man I live in there man I will
be showing up tomorrow I don't want
people show very early marriage a killer
to go past oh babe you wanna smoke a
bowl I know but everyone hit a bone now
bro double Diane you gotta be careful
were so fool what else you got
yeah so Nate will be in June man a lot
of we're gonna have um like if you're
looking for clothes you know an iron is
broken you want to stop by and say hi
man you know lingers the liquor room
shut up to cro-magnon uh bread hock
red hot so he bother he bought merge bro
he's the one that made the meme about
Flaco the ambulance from Flacco's limo
never showed up he gave me a shopping
bag you know for Whole Foods uh he gave
me a shirt a hoodie and though oh that's
cold man crow man yeah
gave me authority work-at-home food yeah
he would know we met him at Whole Foods
can grow bag he's a vegan he's a hero
half a little bit closer yeah yeah yeah
he has his eye at a lot yeah he's like a
hardcore addict I should be a tool
abroad I did heroin coke and PCP at the
same time
well some fool all right man so anything
you wanna add bro any shoutouts people
god no just uh the Riverside show is on
for next week at Romano the concert
lounge with the autumn and Ocasio he'll
be in the house and eat Chinese food
tortillas a and thank you very much for
everybody that came out to the other
loss portico show and what's Covina
we'll be having one again we'll let you
guys know before we start man anything
else other than that to check out the
air man podcast okay this is my
editorial the my editorial column of the
week my column this is gonna really
upset it be man this week I mean I guess
it really upsetting me a lot I just
can't shake it off bro let us know I
wanted to tell you in Tempe but I want
to lose my mind what happened so I was
bugging I got to do it Gabriel ACS
fluffy what happened you know that you
know that focus he did a whole month
right if you do stand-up comedy but I
love his sickness or whatever personal
issues right right he was training it he
was training you know and he was sick
and you know he give away he gave up
public power half a million dollars
worth of work right right because he was
sick right more probably a lot more
probably a million and um he was sick
right and he was he did like a little
bit of Tours and not too much you know
but he's trying to be sure to go out
less and less you know with people man
so this was a man I mean this chick
posted a photo my brother wants to go to
your show so bad
he's in the hospital now can you go see
him but you know can you go see him so
obviously like he's too busy he little
tour bus he don't have time to stop make
a u-turn go get boat to see this guy
right
this chick had all her friends tag him
all day
are you slaw day [ __ ] the hell out of
ugh you the hell let him tag
and I'm tagging a reposted a reporting
it reposted it tagged legless [ __ ]
lingering as this
I mean her son and her brother died
right what is a lot of sick people bro
he do to save them anyway I know man but
you I heard a give us out that miracle
water though the Vatican or whatever and
water will you do the miracle water bro
and I [ __ ] your [ __ ] wolf or chick
shows up early gonna double tax break
here oh [ __ ] I just man I just urge me
that they lady like she didn't go she
did didn't she go back a month ago and
find out that he's sick too
oh yes you have time to go there and
shake hands man he's gonna haul her but
if you show up if you not showed up
he's to Hollywood what an ass or what an
[ __ ] here what a piece of [ __ ] killer
they think about us anymore
he just thinks about is both wagons you
know what I mean I was just upset me bro
like I get it how well [ __ ] yourself
forgot [ __ ] dog that's how I get a
burger stick he's alright Karen Cator
doesn't have a healing power to cure him
hey that's gonna be other shows not a
physician lady oh man the nerve the
nerve growth I know what's going to
happen next year right gonna get whether
her brother died you say brother dies
right you don't die oh man the example
is gonna happen if her brother Lee
doesn't that dies our brothers dead gay
bro you know were sad you know I thought
maybe you give us free tickets bro for a
whole family and we could get all REO
neither like we were at the hospital
together the day we show up and we could
just take photos in honor of my dear
brother that would have been a nice
letter now this is a letter if that
[ __ ] brother was not would've not died
our man
my brother is alive because you put a
big smile in his face
but of the hospital bills has been
[ __ ] us up and and we have no money
to go to your show anymore because if
the tickets are like $35 I was thinking
that if you could like maybe if there's
any extra tickets you know okay and so
she got the extra chickens but this is
the
email after you get the ticket hard
Gabriel is there any way man that you
could get us because we're in the back
of the line right now and we're trying
to get in and my brothers in a [ __ ]
wheelchair and we're just trying to get
into a show man
okay now they're in the show right Oh
Gabriel we're in the show man we're
wearing a back seat man
I thought maybe we could go backstage
and meet you man
my brother wants to thank you now man
because of your of your miracle water he
can walk now man hallelujah look at four
a lot huh oh my god I want to just make
a part of his act and moving in the
house that reminds me bro of that Bob
and Tom show Bob and Dave show
yeah when they go through their little
bird [ __ ] a little wristband a
little journey yes yes if you know how
hard it is to go visit a bird
[ __ ] right dude but this will
put it let's go with your life right now
with what's going on with you fool how
many people try to get at us don't I
understand it dude each of those tickets
or I say you give somebody a ticket all
right it's a value of 25 bucks
you still got to pay the club that value
that they sell to you for whatever it's
valued at it costs you money if you give
somebody a shirt you paid for that [ __ ]
yeah I mean you're not going to get it
for what you sell for but you pay to get
that's right I just got an effort to get
that shirt to your show the nerves oh
those are understand like where were you
with the hospital you go Vinny with the
hospital oh man oh we're for a little
bit the kicker there'll be a chocolate
cake waiting for you oh yeah those
really awful diabetic [ __ ] yeah kill
each other kill him people give him
kinks right it happened oh nerve man I
would like I would man oh I probably
would've went to but still mad or
nervous keep asking but that's why
people get so reclusive do you can't you
can't in any ways I do Jesus Christ
couldn't satisfy everybody let it you
guys that's what they thought good I
don't think you said about uh he's sick
like like you battled some stuff right
you know I battled some stuff like when
it's fresh you're on a Razors Edge and
people got to respect that
Lytle respected like even that you turn
to go back might be just enough to put
somebody back on the bad path
it's [ __ ] amazing what these people
want this pull over the your I notice on
your tracking that my tracking device
Gabriel that your bus it's gonna make a
left turn around 10:59 p.m. the really
possible way that me and my son to stop
by there in that corner at that at that
[ __ ] cross light and you can just
barely jumped off and just take a photo
real quick like my son will really
appreciate you know my son gets all a's
at school and here is a union and i'll
bring a cake and i'll bring a cake
Jesus you're not awful not and you're
always understand how a person how
people how someone could be Hollywood
bro
Wow like to do I'll tell you an emotion
Hollywood guy is right here next to it
yeah right
I know me with a mission Latino writers
his name pops up it does that's right if
you have Peter Moore yet that we have
enough week or Latinos who say hey I
want to tell you about Hollywood I'll
tell you about how I love you I'll see
them for a year to hear people all
writer for the peace teller show o
writer for the [ __ ] gonna show
Wizards of Waverly playing on a show you
know Jungshin Photoshop so here
doughnuts
the writer Lopez reader I'll pass okay
very sound Wizards Wizards of Waverly
Place they show their first order was
begging to be on every week I'm ready
bring me back so let me tell you real
quick about Hollywood it's so funny
brought that up Google my kid when he
was younger he played Little League with
Willie Barcena yeah dinner Willie story
though Tigers approachable bro but but
it was one of item we were up there you
know and I was working I think I was
working on Wizards you know whatever and
my wife had an invitation she got from
the temple we belong to because she's
Jewish
and they were like we're having a dinner
to raise money to bring over this
celebrity Cantor and I don't even know
what that means we do it was so
important it does it's very important
yeah so he sings in the temple and he's
from Israel we're bringing him over
and it's like $1,000 a plate to go to
dinner to raise money right a washroom
and I say I'm totally good with the guy
we got now I don't I'm good I don't need
to spend that money we don't have that
kind of money
this one from Bethlehem yeah we're good
we're good this one's from Bethlehem
we're good we got the guy local guy like
the local guy so then a week later I go
up to the Little League and it's an Echo
Park and I love it there and I love
Sergio who runs it and we having a
parent meeting and somebody says hey the
microwave and the snack stand broke and
we're going to have a car wash on
Saturday after the game to raise money
to get a new microwave almost that much
glue about 300 bucks you know right
comes from Israel no it's a big one
right for the big boys okay okay so I
say and I'm not trying to be Hollywood I
just say well that's like 300 bucks
right and I'm like they're like yeah I
like I could just buy it for you and
then at all mr. Hollywood doesn't want
to get involved in the car wash doesn't
want to come out wash cars with
everybody so I was like no no no no I
just want to spend traitor bucks for
your microwave and got totally Hollywood
I come a big [ __ ] you know and those
piece of [ __ ] the real the rather
[ __ ] struggle brother cuz I pay them
that [ __ ] right there
[ __ ] all that because they know in the
car wash the car where they could
squeeze eggs out of it they're gonna be
able to get my photography heard about
it but I should better gonna microwave
but no other they don't know how much
ego in a car wash yeah how many
donations they got you know because it
takes a yeah there's no but there's no
envelope to be a problem that's right
that's right
Miss Rose that's right you know anyway
yeah they're just you know Hollywood so
I also feel like from what I was
listening to when I first came in here I
just need to say I don't even understand
why but I'm a 36 32 36 hours don't belie
but I'm not I'm not lose 36 and sure
alright I'd 36 all right you were like
old man style but the budget last year
no it goes it goes underneath the gut
okay well in elastic right
that's showing on here yeah I only go
about five nine guys it's so fat just so
laughs a friend of ours right not so
much weight it's because he is really
sick but not doing well we were trying
to guess his weight and I was thinking
such as such it 429 3000 very like high
school yeah that's high school pull your
greedy baby haha I just caught my Levi's
yeah yeah we got Peter here bro though
that Peter was a shock collar boy in my
development deal bro hell yeah yeah yeah
that was fun uh-oh you're working on
yeah yeah working hard for hard and
maybe my favorite thing that I've worked
on it really hard huh it was really fun
and I loved the script we got out of it
and we'll see what happens next you know
we're gonna sort of shoot it again next
time right oh yeah what fozzy like right
yeah yeah yeah that was flooded my
liberal I never ever been involved with
anything like that it was good just
beating every day my favorite story
about that and you got to tell it from
your point of view but we went into ABC
we've been working for eight months we
ready to pitch you know the story I'm
going to tell without Dave minor so we
walked in the door we all get situated
downstairs we get upstairs I got to go
to the John I leave my managers there
and with all the goodness in your heart
you lean over to Dave and you say hey we
should maybe mention when we get in the
room that Peters Mexican so no no
because you know yeah that doesn't look
like it and my manager goes no no no no
they know him he's exactly the right
amount of Mexicans for them we need to
make sure they know that you're okay
yeoman that's Hollywood Hollywood right
and how'd you guys meet well how did
that mean that I think we met and I
don't know if you remember this but we
met years ago when I went over to Lucy's
El Adobe because um Freddy Soto and
Willie and al Madrigal and I had a
sketch show that we had sold a Sony and
then Freddie died
and they were still trying to put it
together and they were like you got to
go meet Gabriel because maybe he'll do
it and we went over to Lucy's and
Gabriel was there with you and noe and a
couple of other guys Oh Lucy's car
whooshes uhh no the Mexican food on
Melrose
oh yeah and we sat and talked to you for
about an hour and that's when I first
met you all day remember
losses were it's our Millers by
Paramount right across the street but
that's when I first met you then then
you know what years and years and years
and then met you again last year because
you you were working with dustin ybarra
how did you connect with him Dustin and
I met because of Hollywood our agents
already like how he's wants to do
something yo so dude put it together
yeah put them together we're both of the
same agency we both like each other and
I went met him at somewhere on Sunset to
see if we would get along um we'll get
to that but um with our story but you
were like they were connect you were so
would you just imagine I got lucky with
this guy yeah I got click this man here
yeah
worst one how'd it happen um how do you
not connect
I'm not Holly unite cuz I thought like
you that would write on her board to
just go with the flow and yeah yeah you
try you try you try just don't click
well like there's a guy like I like
there was a guy that they wanted me to
mean and I'm Matt and like I got a call
before the meeting and they were like oh
his manager wants to be a part of this
and I was like that's cool but this is
the first date like let's just see if if
we vibe and whatever first you know I
don't really want to jump in all the way
on that and then they were like no no
that's cool we get it we get it we get
it and then I sat down to meet with this
guy and like I don't know 10 minutes
into is that a diner
10 minutes into it 10 minutes into it
worst acting I've ever seen in my life
give another booth from another booth
the manager gets up and goes oh my god
oh my god what a what crazy coincidence
I can't believe it
I I really I swear to God I had no idea
you guys are meeting here
oh my god and then he sits down and
becomes part of the meeting and like so
I'm in the middle of this it's like
being on a bad first date we were like I
want to leave now but I can't so I have
to pretend to go along with it for
another 45 minutes and then bail so I
could super guest movie Eugene everybody
kind of does it kind of does or like
that old movie with Kevin Bacon we're
like managers yeah the right I'm short
it's like hey I hate you I hate you call
me like that I am do some early G [ __ ]
huh it is like an episode of Hollywood
Squares right right right right
anyway I don't know oh the chocolate of
my peanut butter yeah what about that so
there's that oh that's a Hollywood yeah
killed me with a bad acting oh my god oh
my god oh my god I can't believe I'm
gonna do that was good yeah dude how
about anybody that keeps saying over and
over again I swear to God I had no idea
and you're like wow I think you had
totally enough got the suspect yeah Wow
but so you do but you do try to go with
the flow you try to meet people and try
to see if you can help him so he working
with dustin ybarra and i working with
bobby right hmm I don't know and then
you know Bobby right I know Bobby's my
neighbor he's your neighbor
yeah just talking yeah we just were
walking down the street I was gonna get
coffee
I'm gonna go Britain bro and he he were
talking about what are you doing what
are you doing I was like I'm doing this
thing with Dustin doing things Felipe
guy no Felipe he has low here and and
and then we started talking about we
were trying to do and we're like well
obviously at some point we're both going
to be pitching a show competing with
each other why don't we figure out if if
these guys get along maybe we could do
something together and then and here's
what we could probably spend all day
talking about then we had to do because
Bobby's a smart guy and a good guy and
I'm a good guy I think and try to be a
smart guy were like well first we have
to find out if Felipe and Dustin have
beef because I don't want to start
something and find out there's trouble
right because you want you want to do
that and so we checked in and you know
like no I think he's great great and so
then we met up to talk but like there's
so much beef everywhere when you get
involved have you ever had any
experiences that we
you didn't know beforehand and then you
got together and there was internal
clashes or stuff like that that happened
uh-huh
beef who men who was well you know a
long time ago you know I tried to help
out Willie with something and he had
shot something on his own and I tried to
come in and give him notes after the
fact with a management that said uh that
sure that Willie was working with Jay
Leno
oh no that's even before that when he
when he was working to change a little
trouble that movie he shot a small movie
about him being a dad like on his own
yeah and and a the real dark boy was
doing coke uh uh
oh man without no an absolutely no
matter to an outdoor show Jay Leno won
the Jay Leno one actually is the way I
met Willie was somebody wrote that
script this is when I first got to town
first got to Hollywood someone who want
that script I don't remember his name
if there was a guy fro Seinfeld a really
named along here don't know
uh he's long hair long hair and he would
he would like facilitate one there Larry
Charles and there Charles okay oh wow so
he wrote the first script and for
whatever reason he's I wrote it was up
with really really what time okay so it
for whatever reason it didn't go forward
and then I was new to town and my agent
sent me to meet somebody over at NBC and
exact and then we after the meeting was
over because I think I talked about when
I was a kid I used to my grandfather was
a mechanic at a car dealership okay I
said oh we have this show about a guy
who works at a car dealership that Jays
doing with this guy Willie Barcena
and it needs somebody to come in and do
a rewrite and so I got that was like one
of my first Jobs was meeting with Jay
and working with Janis rewrite for
Willie cool and it was super cool Jay
was super cool like it's so funny
because when I started meeting with him
was sort of after the Letterman thing
and people were picking sides and
everything and and and I was like wow I
don't know when I go meet him he's
incredibly nice and he's incredibly
funny and really smart like I don't have
anything bad to say about him and it was
a great experience but then towards the
end of it and I don't know what happened
the network was like Willie's out
not doing it I don't know if he pissed
on really off or what happened but like
it's not going on so was one of those
situations where I finished the rewrite
and turned it in just to get my check
and but I knew it was not happening but
then later he he shot something on his
own with some managers it wasn't the one
we were doing coke but something about
dad and he used the baseball field we
all worked on and and I went in to give
him notes on it and you know I guess he
kind of had beef with me and I didn't
know about it and I kind of walked into
it and it was like a lot of stuff that I
didn't have any idea about and I felt
bad about and I got the hell out you
know I'm like I don't I'm volunteering
my time so didn't feel right I'm not
going to jump into someone who wants to
be critical of me as a person I'm good
after that what you do I'll do how'd you
get started with wizards wizards was a
thing where I would read it right I did
not actually on the title card create
thing everybody you create that's fine
you're the show I was a showrunner you
know showrunner what's a soul runner for
people don't know it's somebody who's
the head writer and also served as
earlier and and make sure that the
director you get you want he's kind of
in charge of the show in charge of
delivering the show everything those
three very good all the bad calls again
lazy actor yeah all of it all delivered
sad news or sad news for you good news
now I do it ooh tough tough tough tough
so he was gonna love you go to your
office
yes so you could just you literally
could do what Steve Harvey did ah I got
approached me I could I used to have my
assistant was one of my one of my
assistants jobs was when I was leading
my office to go to the set or to my car
or to editing one of his jobs was to
walk with me with like a clipboard or
some papers or whatever and act like we
were talking about something super
important because I was like I just I've
got no need to be bothered right now I
need to get where I'm going so I did the
sun'll version of The Steve Harvey play
like I didn't make an announcement I was
like I'm gonna be super busy when I
leave here so nobody can kind of grab
hold of me but but I came back from New
York I was doing a show and Disney
handed me a script called the amazing
O'Malley's and it was
an Irish family that owned the magic
shop and had powers and I read it and
they asked if I wanted to get involved
in it and I was like well sure but
there's some things I'd like to change
and I think because I'm half in half
it'd be cool to make the family half in
half and find some Latino actors and
stuff like that and maybe move it out of
a magic shop and have it be more fun
environment or whatever and so they let
me do that and and that's how we started
that show so that was my job
are you million Latino yeah that's a
second ten diminish or Latino cause Dora
the explora was that was about to be a
little Irish girl oh yeah without being
less even yeah we were really Latino
yeah yeah and I was oh yeah go ahead
cool the lead Selena Gomez really Google
is blog and and Maria canal's Pereira
she was on the mom Costello show right
he's on cristela quick Stella sister and
David DeLuise Dom DeLuise his son for
anybody in the members Hollywood Squares
and yeah it's fun it was great time for
four years I did three years and then
Disney fired me and I didn't do the last
year gonna bother you
ah I think I was difficult I wanted
things my way and I think they grew
tired of that to be fair but I was
making a great show and we won three
Emmys so I thought I thought we were
cool that's good to know
I thought we were cool but turns out we
weren't so I didn't do the last year
would you was like after that I did a
show for Cartoon Network but was
live-action called level up it was about
a bunch of kids who had some monsters
come out of a video game in their town
and they had they're like really fight
monsters and put it back in the video
game so it's kind of like Dungeons &
Dragons are like World of Warcraft come
to life the real Romano's mom come on in
that one ah a couple episodes no I
started a movie where she will stay
computer but I growl no no no you know
who was in that was a Meeker arrow who
does a lot now she's the voice of Elena
the the first Latina Disney Princess oh
and the guy Jesse usher who's on a show
that LeBron James produces now
and Eric Andre was in the pilot oh yeah
of it yeah and then he was like I'm
gonna do a crazy thing where I take off
my clothes instead of this kids show so
he bailed and and so I did that and then
I didn't wanted to get into more back
what I started which was a lot more
adult primetime stuff and so then I
wanted cristela and then I did Lopez and
I did one day at a time in that superior
doughnut you were gonna Lopez the show
now a little bit the original show no
they did the Shelly is doing now but you
were not always Hollywood how you were
Tucson guy Tucson guy RDR tomorrow yeah
a little bit
sold out you were sober how long oh gosh
26 years 26 years old so you started out
working at Hollywood a writer when you
sobered up oh yeah I wasn't a mout here
sober and married would you do it a to
subtle gang banging all of it
yeah no I'm not gang banging no ah but I
did whatever you had man whatever you
had I do that's me right there yeah
[ __ ] oh yeah so you could Starling
man everybody anybody as a party says
hey we found these pills we don't know
what they are who who would who would oh
okay Judah Peter yeah he'll do it the
book in here Andy yeah yeah I remember
being on a roof of a house during a
party and thinking if I tuck properly I
could jump off this roof from somersault
and come up standing I've never doing
[ __ ] like that and you know didn't work
out so great no bones broke it but I
remember landing and thinking I'm just
gonna lay here Wow
I was gonna lay here a while and were
you working there like as a writer like
well we go to college I was in college
and I was trying to get a degree that I
didn't and guys doing sketch comedy work
at a little theater downtown and did
some plays and stuff but nothing you
know that didn't start till Chicago I
moved to Chicago in 89 oh I saw second
city come to Tucson and I was like oh I
want to do that Moochie Chicago rejoice
bigger city yeah yeah I loved it so fall
over there five years but over guy yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
a couple slips but yeah working hard
there what would you sober up
I was asleep in the abanda in a
construction site of an office building
that was just framed but it wasn't built
out and I was sleeping on a pallet of
drywall because I was on the run and I
didn't want people come to my house
because I'm going to steal my [ __ ] and I
thought this is not probably a long-term
plan but that was sort of my bottom
right there like okay that's what could
be done with that that's probably time
to start figure something else out and
so that's when it started so but you
were crazy in high school like be a run
ah I think I started it in high school
but I was trying to still keep my [ __ ]
tight like I was trying to get good
grades but not studying much and trying
to kind of ease on by but doing a little
bit of work and maintaining yeah I was
maintaining I was like a lot of you know
Peters not living up to his potential
from teachers and [ __ ] like that
and then it kind of really went nuts to
college and needed to be corralled I
should get that for my teachers
believers are leaving us with potential
yeah that's a it's a good one other than
over potential yeah yeah yeah and now
that I got kids now that I got kids when
you hear that I know what it means
cuz I'm like okay I'm gonna talk to him
when I get oh did you play baseball in
high school ah I did yeah not very good
though
my son's good yeah but I wasn't very
good did you play yeah up in line learn
the high school team open the swimming
team oh yeah I play Little League and I
played um semi-pro would like Saturday
League and Tuesday League uh-huh I plane
uh-huh yeah hold in that grip I just
like playing I'd find it
I like having two uniforms I used to a
Saturday League when I play with older
men and I have my league on Tuesday with
height with um with baseball high school
dropouts oh nice yeah so our Youngs our
league was down 17 to 19 with the
Tuesdays and the other league was 17 to
whatever age you are it was a lot of
older guys a lot of older guys from Peco
ever who are really good again look at
those guys his hardball or sorry ball
hard ball the I I don't know the names
but one of the guys it was a
coach at my oldest little league used to
play semi-pro so he would come to coach
sometimes in his uni because he was
playing Sunday League or Saturday League
and they would go down to Mexico once a
year and play a team from the town that
they were all from and he came back from
one of these trips like freaked out and
he told me that while they were there
one of the guys on his team got
kidnapped and because I guess they found
out that this guy owned like a tile
company up in the valley was doing okay
and so he got kidnapped and they wanted
to ransom and the [ __ ] got worse from
there
like he was so he's kidnapped and you
know ransom and in the process of
getting the ransom together it comes out
to he's got two families he's got a
family up here and he's got a family
down there so now people are pissed and
so I guess they cut off his finger to
prove they had him they got the ransom
and then he got dropped off in San Diego
went to the hospital two divorces losing
his business and he doesn't have a
finger that's a [ __ ] up weekend one
thumb up that's a [ __ ] up weekend
right there not you live by the sword
you die gasps hello but that is not a
baseball chip you want to take so he
stopped playing baseball I guess he had
to write gentleman luck little boy the
bad boy now I am that's a good story
though how they find out he had two
families I guess I guess they put out
like a notice like to like does anybody
know anybody went through that would
have kidnapped him and whatever yeah and
through the process of the investigation
I guess like his wife called and his
other wife called the hospital or
something and it's all bad all that I
got that place one of the families sent
those people huh now what they do is
they Scout they do all that's I'm saying
they Scout they were like making money
and if you're connected it'll mess with
you if you're not connected and you're
vulnerable they'll get your that and if
you don't act right you see me Doug's is
and now is any crazy looking
[ __ ] than Mexico City you do but
in Mexico City like every block there's
a club Whoopie away it's like they don't
mess around too much but what is like if
you're like a high roller a lot of them
have bodyguards now because real all the
kidnappings are starting to surge again
but that's for people that got money but
and also in those communities like say
for instance the gate guy it'll start
giving in for those guys you know you
know but it's all it's a lot a lot to
deal with and you have to know the game
down there so yeah you know it opens up
new money versus old money on the shade
you know it's not scary to me yeah I
mean if you're used to it or not it is
but I feel like here say when I was
younger before I had gray hair of the
other and I lived in Chicago I would go
to any neighborhood I wanted and I don't
feel like I'm tough but I feel like I
kind of keep my head down I know [ __ ]
where I grew up like I can kind of just
be straight and narrow and I remember my
mom visiting and like we were on the
elevated train and I went over to make a
phone call and she was like alone
and I saw some guys starting to come
around or you know and I always remember
that now that I'm older because I'm out
and about by myself and I think how when
am I going to be the old [ __ ]
at what point am i old enough that
they're going to go there's an older guy
it's not to let's the [ __ ] get him
not yet but I'm worried in my in trouble
I'm people are my trouble but you know
when you're old enough huh well over
would look Portuguese on brother Oh
[ __ ] and that's yeah that's what
I want to know when I read it will you
tell me when I get there Felipe when you
let me know take his wallet sure well
that's how I brought movie kill one
little old little leather leather little
bag with a little metal on it what's
going a black guy got Billy Jack bro
gonna have that
hell yeah mellow do commit were you
saying something Pam yeah Sonya calm
sunny very sunny Willie's in over here
and whack come on the for hit right on
the nose but breaking nose and I don't
think you get ever be too prepared when
it happens you know what no that's the
thing to happen in a big city yeah and
no matter how big you are you all fall
yeah yeah yeah at least expected [ __ ]
but I just I'm counting on you to tell
me what I've turned
it's gonna be up to you that's a lot on
you live your neck
no help when you can't look at your
cellie in the ice over Thursday - with
all these cameras and [ __ ] is going on -
Christ go happens I know I broke people
you know what somebody stole my name
yesterday
somebody stole somebody got that eyelid
the ring the ring the doorbell thing you
know the the you know I'm talking about
it's called the ring right where they
the camera and the doorbell yeah okay
the minute those came out the minute
those came out I thought well if I'm a
dude I'm going to know what that looks
like and if I'm gonna steal [ __ ] from
your porch I'm gonna take that - right
right so sure know that I think that way
bro so sure enough yesterday somebody
said a whole thing about your
neighborhood like someone stole my ring
and I'm in my packages I'm like yeah
that yeah that makes sense
and on top of that you see all those
Facebook videos and everything it's like
you have the river if you're still
getting jacked yeah yeah yeah you know
that's why I had the nest up there
that's what man if you don't want to get
jacked but you gotta order the Dollar
Shave Club bro it comes secured bro but
it's easy tears are hidden bro yeah yeah
we're so fool today's episode is
sponsored by Dollar Shave Club today's
episode Dollar Shave Club Road jingle
uses Dollar Shave Club man look at that
face look at that face moves like a baby
move that would you slap here man you
don't you don't feel no bristles if you
hate face your hand slide another shape
Club those who are hearing the word so
pool party booking has been using it all
month and loved it
we've had some listeners who subscribe
to better shape club already and love it
get your face smooth and ready for
summer by joining
Dollar Shave Club is the smartest choice
in my line Yemen our great shape at a
great price conveniently delivered right
to your door don't have to go to the
store to get more razors no more cheap
shaves like Peter right here in Quito
I'll shave with the old-school one but
that's happened with a leather yeah
comes with the awesome dr. carbon shea
butter which house prevent ingrown hairs
and
by razor bumps you too can make the
smart choice by joining dollar shaper to
you the pros oh yeah dude well that's a
key for me is the dr. Carver's a shea
butter dude that's what gets you really
like nice and smooth oh just give me the
butter
yes secret ingredients one of our
listeners for a limited time new members
get their first month of the executive
razor who's a tube of their dr. Carver's
shea butter for only $5 by bus free
shipping after that month arrays are
just a few bucks a month
that's a $15 value for only five bucks
your first box will arrive and you'll
get an awesome heavy handle razor a
focused set of four cartridges in a tube
of the shea butter and only that man
[ __ ] if you have a razor bump and you're
crying
Gabriel itching will show up and say
hello to you give him a cake just tell
her you ever taken let's go Hollywood
you selfish bastards but you know a man
comes out a man gonna have time to go
visit you something like a person has
other issues brawling here together get
to Long Beach on time at his life is a
funny man like I'm pretty sure they're
not asking a low salary so well bro
I'm sure he does they can't get ahold of
them I think you're right about that no
I think you're right I think those guys
remove themselves from the day-to-day
can special e now social media is so
accessible yeah people know where that
tour bus is yeah
no hidden fees no commitment cancel
anytime you want to get this deal joint
doll joy today at Dollar Shave Club that
comes as pool don't forget
dollarshaveclub.com /foo that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash fool fool
would you say with bros throw bigs
uh-huh I wish a straight race I wish I I
had to use one last week though an old
back an old white pick with the orange
yellow strip yep I shave or the old
safety razor that you got to put the
razor in and a brush in a mug let the
old clothes old a world
hello school right that's what I use and
then I fly back east
all of April is flying back east to see
my boy play baseball and so I didn't
want to check any luggage no we carry
any [ __ ] with me so I'm like [ __ ] it I'm
not taking in that [ __ ] cuz I don't
wanna be inspected yeah so I got back
there and I went to the store and I
couldn't find anything I ended up buying
Vic shavers 99 cents for five it cut you
up over there either like uh be
everywhere cut me everywhere I deserve
it man
so you're something baseball will
college Kenyon Kenny college any college
scholarship oh yeah you got a little bit
so you're so used to play well baseball
Willie Barcena yeah we'll used to be his
coach really yeah ouch be coach [ __ ] I
do come on bro Charlie's yourself is
coachable hey bro I'm at Eleusis I never
played pro ball bro but I wanted God bro
all right bro you guys know Fernando
Valenzuela me neither bro bro TJ wasn't
built today just looks that way bro oh
so get out there and swing bro before I
swing at you bro give me your dad told
you bro your Little League coach broke
anyways bro have a good game bro huh so
I don't jump in the fake laughs that was
a good one bro how are you guys
Charlie's you know a good object work so
we ain't fighting without one other
coach bro hey bro I ain't playing bro
all right bro this baseball bro I'm here
to jiu-jitsu bro Gina
give Mikey
[Laughter]
he knows oh my god I'm gonna kill him
bro why are you saying that bro
when's the last time you saw him Oh
Willie about the photo the ISIS yeah man
he still out you're doing it right oh
yeah you don't mind incident who come he
comes here i'ts a lot yeah he's really
special like every other year what about
no he really goes dollies well I have it
last time I heard about him bro was last
five years ago Brown Lewis Brown now
he's in the abyss somewhere in West
Covina bro oh my god he used to take
classes for my wife really yeah well
before before which was Gabriel she
wrote a frog improv improv is that what
he's hoping for Mencia are those those
better it was before he done anything
really lose a kid working in his parents
restaurant Ravena longer he would drive
in with hot dogs and he would take
acting and improv with her okay and I
remember when he did his first open mic
and she went and supported him and stuff
and then I told her she was with
Philippe and I've heard anything so yeah
I haven't heard about no you know in a
minute it's been a while so what
happened but why cristela so get
cancelled oh I don't know how'd you
become a part of it what happened oh I
just went and met like I had you write
for the show I did write for the show
yeah but but but like when they did the
pilot like we did last year that was
with cristela and my boss other boss
Kevin hench and then when the show got
picked up they met white writers to fill
out the room and I was just one of the
writers that met them and they hired so
I worked for them and you know we did 22
we got her back nine and it felt like we
were pretty close to a pickup and she
just went south you know they just
decided not to do it
what was missing do you think jokes Oh
rumble professional opinion and my
humble professional opinion I don't
think the show is promoted as much as it
should have been but also it was not of
a Fox show huh I'm that child didn't
really commit right yeah and I think it
was like I think it was more about like
ABC feeling like they could do better I
think one of the things that always
happens
time of year is they got their new [ __ ]
coming in and they're weighing it out
and our ratings weren't great they were
okay and I think when they look at that
they go well we got this we know what it
is we got this other thing that's shiny
and new we wonder what the hell it is
and that year it was dr. can dr. Canaan
and fresh off the boat you know yeah but
dr. ken was the thing that's replaced us
and I think probably if I was being
professional about it regardless of the
quality factor which is not mine to say
like professionally and I don't know if
people even care but I think ABC was
like well cristela wasn't as known as
the guy from The Hangover yes we had a
trouble promoting that show so maybe if
we do a show in its place with somebody
who everybody already knows maybe we'll
do better you know and then I don't
think they did much better but they kept
that on another year because I think
they didn't have anything to replace it
well it's not as sexy to say but I think
that's what happened there's Lisa right
on like what I shoulder here picked up
it was five shows not getting picked up
yeah
Paul Rodriguez right yep and apology to
his son and Cheech yep Alberto sure I'll
Madrigal I'm gonna go show to what
you're talking about this year with our
his ears yeah al Madrigal had a show
with someone that I know al a gyro to
fillet we had one Judah pre-owned Gina
had one and the Milligan guy - Angela
starts another show - yeah yeah yeah
so what I think it because Trump got
elected I think I think that there were
a lot of Latino shows this year like I
got more right yeah yeah I think I'm I
think it's hard because the election
happened and I think people realized
that they had been forgetting about a
whole other group of people that maybe
watch TV and they had to race to see if
that me needed to be filled I think that
the challenge every year is how do you
do a show that's Latino that people
think that everybody will watch and I'd
be a veteran
right there you go you said I should
have been a u.s. veteran living in the
shack
yeah yeah I'm sure I'm sure by the way
so were they wrong will conservative use
that doesn't make sense
hi how about conspiracy theories yeah we
probably won't let's do that
we'll do that bro yeah let's do that so
I think I think it's that and I also
think it's hard because I think that
when you put something on the air that
doesn't work it makes it harder for
people to then they to step up and try
again
they get risk adverse and so I think
it's that but I think some will happen
look Lopez got a second season one day
at a time yeah cuz the second season and
you know that's what I'm that's on them
Felice yep and so we'll see maybe next
year I try not to be bitter about that
stuff cuz I got to go go work out right
that's your world you live in
yeah but we got a guy who's actually in
the business bro working we got [ __ ]
comedians crying every day bro [ __ ] he
has room they don't get out you know the
Chad da without even being in there and
they don't actually know what's really
going on - so it's like you know a wild
cat opinion yeah do you think in those
five shows that were do you think
there's any similarities you think
there's any stuff to spin like a
railroad current theme that's always
been oh sure but I think I think I'm
going to talk about I'm going to answer
your question I want to talk about a
movie I saw last night
okay called lowriders oh my god walked
out of the trailer that one Oh buddy
maybe one oldie song everything oh my
god so I went and took my boy commands
yesterday Chinese it also has to
Hollywood
yeah right validated parking dude for
people in the movie theater for me him
to other people they got free tickets
opening I was done by I actually got up
in the middle of it and I was I you undo
course I'm into cars and I was like I
got up in the middle of it I still walk
teen I was like hey I got some emails
and I gotta take a leak like Hollywood
I'm gonna
I'm gonna head out to the lobby and like
in ten minutes if you are into it let's
let's bounce so like I went out and like
ten minutes later I had about like I'm
ready I think as well you know they're
making a new car because the other one
what happened together one and like
maybe we should stay to just see how the
new car looks so I was like all right so
I went in and finish the movie and right
and yeah and I was like okay so we got
in the car to go home and he was like
that started out okay and then it got
really bad and it didn't end badly was
pretty okay at the end because what do
you think happened there and I was like
it felt like I was watching a movie by
people who mean well they want to give a
leg up but they don't necessarily know
what to do besides that I'm talking
about producers or studios so it ends up
being somebody like the three of us that
they go we're going to make a movie for
you guys we get very excited and we're
like what do you want we were so excited
you're going to write a check for us
what do you want what do you want and so
we're going to feed them what we think
they want and what they think they want
which is like a fractured father-son
relationship and then a mom that's dead
and a tribute to the mom and a tattoo
and like the white girl joins a hood the
white girl comes there's a like
Boulevard nights yeah I'll be like [ __ ]
it my name is like the movie um do cover
Oh bro that white girl gets jumped into
the hood she has to learn about Latino
ISM C and I think the only jobs are back
that's how I see her [ __ ] Paris
haters I think it's all good they did
about but then you run after because you
feel so grateful that they're going to
give us a movie or give you a movie that
I don't even think it's selling out
you're just excited and so you're like
oh will you like this and it takes a
special story or project and it's kind
of like the thing we did with Dustin
that you go no this is going to be what
we're going to do and then when they say
in the eleventh hour
Trump got elected is there a way that
you can make this more red state with
the producers we had with my managers we
kind of go we're good like we we we
don't want to run after that hard we'd
love to be on the air but we
we don't know because other people I
knew we're doing like last-minute
rewrites to try to move something into
like we'll move it into a red state and
we'll make an in-law be somebody who's
Republican and stuff like that and we
were like this is a story that we would
speaks to everybody and everybody like
and we're going to just stamina but it
didn't work out yet
yeah but it will it will do you think
the story is yet to be told like an
authentic one on network television that
hasn't been told so far well I maybe
have more mainstream tastes but like I
kind of loved the first George Lopez
show which really was about George
Wright and his weird bad relationship
with his mom and he was in actually
worked in the warehouse yeah and so like
I enjoyed that a lot and the first show
I did which came on the same year was
greetings from Tucson it was about me
and my dad and my mom being white and
that family trying to figure that [ __ ]
out and I felt like that was really real
and you know I think I think when you
step into it and make it really about
yourself you've got a better shot and I
think some of those shows that don't
make it and some of the ones you're
talking about are you ask me like what
are some as you see all the time you
always see like the married couple that
one culture is not agreeing with the
other culture or you see somebody who's
you know trying to an immigrant story or
you see there's certain things you hear
a lot about that you go well what's the
what the cool part yeah but I don't know
is that any good no no that's a good
it's a good answer but it's not
hilarious right they don't but then but
then I mean give props to ABC even
though they didn't film our show we're
in the room we go pitch all networks all
that works in within three days right
and I don't know except for at CBS if
there was a Latino exec in the room but
at ABC we're sitting in the room and we
start talking about our lady mariachis
and the executive we got one
everywhere else we go we have to explain
who they are we said who they were and
Lynne berry who was our ABC executive
who bought the show was like oh I know
who they are you can move on I'm well
aware of them so like what I love is
when I say well-meaning people like
she's smart and she knows that they want
a Latino show so she's out there doing
research she's out there doing her
homework like you said going over my
YouTube videos you know but and that's
right she also shell so mentions your
stand-up very difficult and you go
that's somebody I want to do business
with because you know she's somebody who
wants to get it right she's trying to
get it right trying that's good they
told her no that someone did so will do
yeah and I think as its Hollywood
someone told her not yet because I don't
think anybody ever says now was oh fool
what I really like the shirt off Fred
Perry yeah it's a very sharp it's the
little uh the marks give it a hero take
it off I'll be too big I'm sorry
oh he will be he also will it wasn't for
a shirt a bro when you guys didn't stop
begging bro oh my god is so good
has he heard you do this thing before
but he kind of got a little like a bad
meal and dogs Oh
most of people when I do a president I
don't sound like that really the tape
recorders on El Madrigal Burrell yeah
I'll give me some rounded cost okay hug
I forgot I used to do his voice but I
mean like gotta see him real quick yeah
yeah have you seen him on the HBO show
I'm a tinea no I just seen the last time
I seen was a specialty but you know he's
on this new HBO show oh yeah the one go
time right Showtime Showtime is a
Showtime I'm dying up here from die I
have you seen it
Lobo read a book Freddie Prinze did you
playing Freddie Prinze or he's playing a
guy like Freddie Prinze life is great I
paused Regas okay yeah so drugs so he
said he's Latino the Escobar a comedy
you're but um what do you think would
tell me you're watching TV what do you
think what do you think they're not
doing right I just don't think is that
um even in film and TV I don't think
that Latino shows it like kid
at least you know Pierre seveal to say
that like white middle America and even
like Latinos like in the West Coast in
the East Coast go goddamn I know someone
like that somewhat that's real we're
something more of a setup you know yeah
yeah an actus or something I gotta ask
you because you travel everywhere you
travel everywhere so I just went to Ohio
to get my boy and we drove back home we
drove through Indiana Illinois Kansas
Nebraska Colorado Utah Arizona
California Nevada and we made it a game
we would stop into a town we'd stop into
town lima something Lima Nebraska
whatever five thousand people
Mexican food restaurant right there
everywhere and I'm like they're here
they're here they're here right there
there's just there this and so it's like
you think to yourself sometimes I'm
going to be pitch shows that people are
like well it's got to be sad in this
part of the country or so many marketing
goes well if we put it on the air how do
we appeal to anybody besides the south
but all of us your will so you know
really like in the Midwest there it's
everywhere so you go like it is kind of
there it just has to be sold to somebody
that can sit right and that's that's a
tough part about it yeah yeah the
authenticity factor now you guys
watching Lopez no I watched the first
one first one yeah yeah what's the truth
would have cable you know I'll give you
my Academy disc not GV Academy disc um
but I love that because he's doing he's
playing him oh yeah right
I'll totally he's not a him now not a
great guy thanks mistakes can't make
things work like I love that a day in
the life of yeah um that's what we
should do
yeah we should do we should do your
veteran you live in a shack right yeah
and you work for George Lopez I don't
know the color but Dudamel and you have
a wheelchair yeah and but you can walk
but you have the wheelchair just
full respect for those full of checks
you keep coming yeah yeah yeah do you
sometimes go to a church not your church
but you go to a church in the middle of
service you stand up like they cured you
and only one was selling though the goat
though the God's water our Christian
tells so you're writing for superior
down as a pure doughnut yeah so he saw
Joe Diaz I did he came in and did add a
man to see you [ __ ]
oh my god he was so good he was so good
he played a part that he came in on the
very last minute to do and it had like
two lines and they basically were like
hey do you want to take a walk with me
and we're going to go over here to this
meeting and all week long we had a
stand-in do them and they were supposed
to be mock threatening and have other
characters go holy [ __ ] what's going on
and the whole time because I think he
was on the road or something like
Jermaine and Maz kept telling everybody
like don't change those lines don't
worry about it when Joey gets here it'll
work bring it to life and he came and it
was chilling right where you walk
sitting on dude he's [ __ ] fat yeah
good Joey brah I'm just acting myself
Felipe what do you want me to do this is
what I do
I said give me a [ __ ] line but I'll
give it life I said last one from me
round you get a lot of lies lat lives
are so I [ __ ] do I'm like [ __ ] the
touch of Christ you know I'm saying well
I'm with the good things from the bad
peace you know I'm saying think about a
little bit I take a shower about the
character and I go in there [ __ ]
killing a limoncello Italian have you
thought more Italian Lisa it's a
recorder but a little bit with recording
rules
I'm saying what the golden jewel it
doesn't matter because God is recording
you know saying oh yeah anyways I also
work with you more few more bro hahaha
want to write it all down
see us a few more hey [ __ ] uh give me
some shine Tony though job Tony
oh man and Dan st. Germain you know him
no no doesn't understand up he's in the
other circuit right on you know I mean
Oh
yeah well so fool jiggle what you guys
coming up now to just this show will be
her vine [ __ ] we got a Riverside on
Wednesday with Armando co-ceo and myself
special guest and yeah man took up the
you show you're working on superior
donuts I'd say right now that's it
here's who driving the old car the black
one oh yeah 75 Plymouth
so Joe the Eau de bison our car bro yeah
I mean I understand he could live in the
same neighborhood the police go stop on
Brook
okay you know I did buy that and please
press that right here I just bought a
new truck
oh yeah oh yeah I love it well coach oh
so you couldn't buy you a chilidog show
bro yeah that's 150 man they said just a
jive truck man just a Ford truck about
us now I have a Toyota Tacoma a little
economical aluminum engine yeah under my
own per tank what are you driving I'm
not driving nothing bro not have a Prius
yeah
and a Volvo you got a Volvo you a maniac
mansion wagon mom my third Volvo man
I've as I'm involved with in my life
that's our main card of death and the
other one there's more Volvo's in my
neighborhood than the cars I got yeah
for sure
oh yeah man um I got two more questions
go for it alright my second question I'm
going to leave on my second question and
then end with my first question because
I don't you know I messed it up already
but uh what's your favorite city to play
do you have like a favorite club or
favorite side of the Northwest Oregon in
Portland
Spokane yodel Yakima okay I can actually
say Spokane this last times okay really
off the what's great about that say just
not hot
yeah it's all this with our soul dolls
you know everybody loved the show all
howtechs is good oh yeah always Houston
but also a big surprise to is Utah dog
Sonic's our suyo about something
everything everybody's more uptight oh
my god the cars were [ __ ] awesome oh
my god
Tampa was good to armed let me throw
through Utah and I've drove into these
tiny towns because I heard this podcast
about
Mormon separatists that still practice
polygamy yeah they do polygamy believe
you
and I wanted to I went with I went into
this tiny town where they had still
happened and it was crazy man there was
there was no lie there was a cafe called
the Merry Wives cafe oh wow I'm like
it's right out there in the sign they're
not even trying to hide it's crazy crazy
and then my boy wanted to stop in the
temple and get a book of mormon and talk
to him because I think he's like doesn't
understand the religion he just likes
the idea of like a lot of wives I don't
think he knows yet
and then my next question is mariachi
Manchester yeah I love them what are
they doing what's happening are they do
you worried look I was out there huge
they have it on you they're so good yeah
okay so good is there bad as hell just
do met you oh yeah my shoulders show
good a lot of shirt I guess yeah and I
might I wanna I want to support them
like what we need to help them you'll do
it on tour right now I think they were
opening up for Chicano Batman a couple
of shows I'll me that up I thought you
were though cuz I'm Adela was Yeah right
after right before they did the show
with you over at the nobo they toured
Mexico yeah that's where Mexico lit up
all their bad it sounds really good so I
like the whole little acoustic version
of it you know yeah games and all that
[ __ ] and then oh good so good so rich
the the Maz yeah more yeah so um do I
need to like do anything else did I mess
it up how'd I do well you're great I'm
sorry I'm doing okay they're doing good
yeah but you have a podcast you do as
well right the remarkable I do that's
funny that you bring it up we're kind of
on the hiatus right now but yeah eight
episodes you know I produce it my friend
Ezra is the host and it's a podcast
that's sort of like half written half
improvised that's about two people that
are fascinated with superheroes like
they really exist and then the bachelor
orders to everything the background
stories are like hey did you hear we saw
this guy took this building down and now
we've got a henchman to come in and tell
us what it's like being a henchman and
we got a sidekick who's been kicked out
that's going to tell us about
being a sidekick or like we had a woman
come in whose job was as a book rep to
rep an autobiography of a superhero that
also sexually molested her and so it's
sort of likes remarkable husband yeah so
it's like a weird fiction kind of show
that is a little bit of reality in a
little bit fiction that's badass yeah
totally yeah a little bit yeah
Oh still a little yeah even the thing we
did a pilot yeah even the thing we did I
always like feeling a little like a
little extra makes it a little less than
just regular for sure you know like we
had our little our ladies yo good
traveling around singing about local
airport yeah yeah yeah and uh you know I
think what you know we need to do is see
if we can get a I think we need to get
Eva Longoria to play the sister and then
we'll be on TV
so we'll I love you tight so she listens
right yeah she's a listener so like of
the podcast shout-out to Corpus Christi
Yammer yeah she the lowrider oh yes she
was the best thing in lowrider if she's
listening see ya man well so full peter
moriata in the house ladies gentlemen
yemen shout out to him and his
grandfather who pretend to speak spanish
another true story
oh my grandfather is my great-great
great-great-grandfather he would pretend
to speak he would don't know English oh
he pretended in no English he was a
bandit and he pretended in no English
and right into a town and see you know
if the posse was looking for him and he
would join the posse and then if they
did know where his hideouts where he
kill everybody and then if they didn't
know he'd ride away and you know keep
the middle highway out to him right hmm
think that right away right here team is
it yeah the best argument is yes my
right we have to work the board the big
rubber there's a couple of I know
there's an on call there is that's not
aimed at him but Eleanor I wield on a
fourteen okay maybe not married a lovely
encased them yeah they chased them off
the 14 we killed them there and they
named a little highway oh that's right
and this little plaque fighter they
mention him on blood and blood out
really oh they do that's what
Murrieta CA I guess oh really yeah yeah
but he wasn't even I already was in
Mexican is that true he was oh he was he
was an aura and some Sonora so Laura my
more people are from Sonora to the law
area my chin Janice was a tiny village
tiny village and my my my son's name
icing all right just example words offal
Peter Murrieta right here man we just
touched the surface will have a back
again thank you very much fun
hahaha Willie Barcena at oh yeah oh [ __ ]
you baseball games - my report back of
bars are heard right
hi he has a temper man he has a temper
we talked about bro
Oh Wars oh good you're the killer